it is great to be joined once again by
economist Richard wolf professor
emeritus at my alma mater the University
of Massachusetts a visiting professor at
the new school University in New York
City a professor wolf you had this great
article recently on the democracy at
work website called the contradictions
of Finance and it talked in in very
interesting terms about some of the
inherent contradictions of our financial
system and it really got me thinking
more broadly about some of the
contradictions that exist in sort of on
our planet for lack of a better term
I'll start more broad than where you
were in the article and let you take us
wherever you want and the contradiction
that I'm sort of thinking of is our
system which includes everything from
lending stock markets increased
consumption as something to be sort of
in never-ending ly a pursued is based on
the idea of unlimited growth but we have
a planet which is of a limited size it
contains limited resources it does at
least theoretically although according
to many we are very far from that limit
it will only house a certain number of
humans and to me that is one of the most
interesting sort of inherent
contradictions in the way we think about
our planet and economies I'll turn it
over to you and you can tell us sort of
how your article ties into that or feel
free to comment in any way you see fit
well I think you make a very good point
and it is generalizable people once
thought that there were unlimited
supplies of trees the European Economic
Development over the last five thousand
years has taught the people of Europe
that there are not in fact unlimited
numbers of trees and they can't use wood
as a fuel and they can't use wood in the
way they once did and they found other
things to do but there were very
difficult transitions to make and we are
now discovering that having shifted from
wood for example as a fuel to coal and
then to
fossil fuels like oil and gas they also
produce horrible side effects and have
limits so that you might have thought
the population would have been trained
by now to understand the contradictions
and to not be so glib about imagining
the limitlessness of whatever it is
they're doing rather than paying
attention to what the quote-unquote side
effects were which can come back and
become more important than the thing
itself and there are plenty of other
examples let me just give you two that
are very pertinent today yeah oh one the
capitalist system of the world crashed
in 2008 and most people of the world are
still living in the aftermath and in the
consequences of that crash in order to
try to cope with it the central banks
around the world the leading financial
institutions in each capitalist country
here in America the Federal Reserve
pushed interest rates way way down to
where they are today
barely above zero in many parts of the
world and downright negative in Japan
and Europe and in parts of the United
States now
well that was supposed to be a recovery
mechanism but here's the contradiction
because interest rates were so low we
now have the highest level of
indebtedness by American corporations in
the history of the United States we have
a level of indebtedness of corporations
all over the world like that they all
took advantage of these very low
interest rates to borrow money like
there was no tomorrow and if there is an
economic slowdown at any time and many
predicted for this year or next then it
is a very dangerous situation to have an
economic slowdown at a time when
corporations are weighed down by debt
they are required to repay
and may not be able to and we may be
looking at another crash that's a
contradiction that people were not
willing to deal with and think about for
the last eight years of keeping interest
rates at this low level last example is
to make it clear to folks there's
another part of capitalism that has
always mystified many economists who've
looked at every capitalist Enterprise
large medium and small is constantly
trying to save on labor costs you
considered a clever effective business
man or woman if you can reduce the
number of workers you need to produce
your output or you can in some way get
less expensive workers to replace the
more expensive one we know that
companies go overseas to do that we know
that they bring immigrants into the
country to move in that direction and so
on but here's the contradiction if
capitalists in their competition with
one another are indeed successful either
in reducing the number of workers they
need or in paying workers less and
especially if they do both and let's add
if they can replace high-cost workers
with less expensive machines what we
used to call automation well then
there's going to be a problem because
with fewer people earning less money you
can't sell the output of those very
enterprises that congratulated
themselves on reducing their labor costs
in other words you may save on labor but
you're gonna pay a heavy price in the
inability to sell what you produce now
this these are real contradictions that
present all of modern capitalist
economies the ecological one this
problem of lowering your labor costs the
problem with lending and they reflect on
a system whose contradictions are not
just some matter for academics to debate
about but these are very real stumbling
blocks that the system puts in its own
way
there's the to piggyback on this idea of
your winning as a corporation if you are
saving on the labor side but then you
are actually creating a situation where
fewer people can then afford to buy your
products or services we have another
contradiction that comes to my mind
which is on the one hand we've sort of
made one of the championed ideas of our
system that of being able to buy and
consume more that's one of the great
things that our system allows people to
seek and rewards and is seen favorably
by society but at the same time we've
seen that same system create larger than
ever
wealth and and income inequality gaps
and it actually makes it so that
consumption that is so revered is also
something that becomes more difficult to
do and it's similar to this idea of at
the individual corporation level that
you mentioned but it's sort of the idea
of what the system is set up to allow
and what it actually allows isn't it
absolutely the metaphor that I found
useful in the classes that I teach goes
like this that what we do in the realm
of consumption and advertising to people
as to what the good life requires you to
buy and then making it impossible by
means of limited wage increases by means
of having to carry debt that means you
have to take a certain amount of your
weekly pay and put it aside to pay off
your past debt and don't even have it
available for consumption now it's a
little bit like that horrible example
when you have a little dog and you teach
the dog to jump for a biscuit but each
time the dog jumps you raised the
biscuit a little further so he jumps a
little higher but you raise it a little
further
eventually you drive the dog crazy with
the sheer frustration of such a level of
non success and not to push it too far I
do believe that the more inequality we
have the more we are treated to seeing
of the super-rich with their yachts and
their apartments and their ski chalets
and their fancy cars and they and the
industry that caters to all of that the
more the distance between all of that
and what most of us can afford the more
the sense of bitterness of frustration
showing up in our politics these days
showing up in the rage that so many
people feel and that occasionally
explodes you're talking about a society
whose contradictions are becoming a
problem of the dysfunction of this
system as a whole last thing I want to
touch on you mentioned politics is there
anything that is substantively different
between the policies suggested by to the
extent we can understand them at least
with regard to - well maybe both of the
major candidates but certainly one in
particular Donald Trump and Hillary
Clinton is there anything that big
picture in terms of the economic system
that we have that would be different if
one or the other were to be elected
president frankly I don't think so I
think the major thing that both of those
candidates are doing is pretending that
these contradictions don't exist and
aren't of a scale that they need to
worry about either they ignore them
altogether or in some kind of sick
mockery propose things that will
actually make them worse or on the other
hand propose the most modest kinds of
marginal adjustments whose scale is way
less than what the problem demands it's
sort of like being given a diagnosis of
cancer and having someone suggest well
Wow with a diagnosis like that I'd go
out and buy more band-aids that you
currently have and you have to say to
such a person goodness the scale of what
you proposed relative to the problem I
have is kind of virtuous up virtually
indecent in its pretense that I'm not
confronting a much bigger
my fear is that American politics at
least of the two major parties is an
effort to distract to deflect onto
personalities and who's telling more
truths and who isn't and who's got this
kind of style and another these are all
a little bit like watching distracting
television or movie because you don't
want to deal with your problems rather
than dealing with an election whose
extensible purpose is to face your
actual problems and try to solve them we
have been speaking with professor
emeritus of economics at the University
of Massachusetts and current visiting
professor at New School University in
New York City economist Richard wolf a
pleasure is always having you thank you
David and I look forward to the next
time